they just want to show so you're a woman
or don't ask a woman what a man needs
don't ask a woman about outfit no no
what speak rationally have a rational
discourse I mean the the point they're
making about don't ask a woman like what
you're talking about dating advice
General like you can't ask a woman when
an alpha is can't ask no matter what
high evaluate well you can't ask a woman
is what what are you talking about you
can ask humans what humans do yeah I
mean you can ask but
usually they talk about dating advice
like don't take dating advice from women
it's like are you asking the fishermen
that's usually what they're talking
about but then wouldn't that also apply
then don't ask men for men advice
because you don't ask the fish like
wouldn't that be don't ask men for men
well see no because men have had to
listen to what women have to say for
years women don't have to listen to what
men have to say that's why it's so
triggering a lot of times when I say
things on this podcast like men know
what we want because they've had to
listen to us for the last 20 30 years
[Music]